[Music]  Selena Gomez is officially the queen of  Instagram for 2016  et has exclusively learned the 24 year  old singer not only has the most  followed celebrity accounts but her  pictures and videos are pretty darn  popular too crazy I just feel really  blessed Selena's most adored clip of the  year this adorable video dancing with a  young fans not far behind this video  celebrating the fourth of July  it's a great feeling to note kind of  Awesome Selena's regal Instagram status  puts her above other standouts like  Taylor Swift ariana grande and Beyonce  the only star who could compete with  Selena when it comes to insta likes  soccer star Cristiano Ronaldo of the top  10 most liked celebrity insta posts of  2016 Selena contributed 8 and Cristiano  - it's extremely touching it's amazing  [Music]  you